- [Brenda] Oh God, oh God, oh God.
This morning's gonna be a sugar rush.
(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, it's Alvin.
I'm gonna be making some
crazy cheesecake tower today.
It's kinda based off of this
idea that's been circling
around the internet called the cherpumple.
It's basically a three-layered cake,
and each layer has a
different cake on the outside
and a different pie flavor on the inside.
So, the word cherpumple comes from cherry,
pumpkin, and apple, which are the pies
that are inside all these
three different cakes.
I was just wondering,
is there a cheesecake
version of this that we could make?
That's my mission today.
So, we'll see how it goes.
- Alvin has been
explaining to me what this
cherpumple business is about,
and I still don't get it.
- So, you want me to
draw what I'm gonna make?
- [Brenda] Yes, please.
- 'Cause do you understand
what I just said at all?
- I think that what you're saying is,
there's gonna be cheesecake,
and there are gonna be layers.
- I mean, you know me and layers, man.
We go way back.
(romantic music)
I need to think about what
flavors I'm gonna pick.
Vanilla and chocolate.
So, those are my two cheesecake flavors.
And as far as the desserts that
they're gonna be wrapped
in, cheesecakes really
go well with brownie, apple pie.
Oh, red velvet's a good one.
I'm probably gonna want two
vanilla and one chocolate.
Chocolate does not go well with berry,
red velvet, maybe banana
bread, not apple pie.
Cinnamon roll is a little weird.
Cookie maybe, but I think it has the
most natural synergy with brownie.
I'm gonna pair the chocolate cheesecake
with a brownie on the outside.
I think cookie dough and cheesecake
is a really great combination.
I'm looking at the other flavors.
Honestly, red velvet's a
really good, solid option.
I'm gonna go with that.
There's gonna be three layers.
I want the top and the
bottom to be vanilla.
The middle one is going to be chocolate.
The sturdiest item needs
to go on the bottom.
I feel like cookie is the sturdiest thing.
Making little chocolate black dots.
That means red velvet
has to be on the top.
So the brownie has to go
around here in the middle.
Call me Picasso, you know.
- This looks amazing.
- Thank you.
- It looks like a fancy mattress.
- Fancy mattress?
It's literally all coming
down to the layers.
It needs to look straight.
It needs to look perfect.
It needs to look clean.
Those are my standards.
And I really wanna make this happen,
but I wanna make it right.
- Let's make it happen.
We've run into major problems.
We can't find the bottom of, what is it?
- The springform pan.
- And if there's no bottom?
- There's no cheesecake.
Where's the bottom?
- We need to find the bottom.
- Alright, I'm just gonna
bring out everything I've got.
Nope, nope, nope.
Nope.
That's gonna be a no from me, dog.
This doesn't work.
Is this gonna?
- [Brenda] Man, that's so little.
- Oh wait, that looks pretty good.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- Oh, nice.
(Brenda claps)
We got it.
(upbeat music)
- [Brenda] This is where the
sexy music begins to play.
(sensual music)
- Here comes the cheesecake.
Yum, yum, yum.
This is just normal brownie batter.
(upbeat music)
Good, one down.
(Brenda claps)
- [Brenda] Look at
Alvin's face, the focus.
Wow, amazing, amazing.
Ooh!
Ah, that look so cool.
What?
- You're the best hype man ever, Brenda.
- [Brenda] There goes the focus face.
(Brenda laughs)
(Alvin chuckles)
- Yo, this batter is mega thick, all caps,
three Cs, spaces in between each one.
You know what I mean?
Now I have to do the
cookie dough one, Brenda.
- [Brenda] Oh my goodness!
I was waiting for this.
- Can I get some help getting
this cookie dough into a bowl?
- Oh my God, I get to help
you build this crazy thing?
- All right, that's good
Brenda, don't worry.
- That's it?
- That's great.
- Oh.
- I thought I was doing
something a little more special.
- I wouldn't task you with that.
- Okay.
- All right, cookie dough's going in.
(smooth jazz music)
- It's like an ancient way of building,
that's pretty cool.
- Are you watching the
right History channel?
I actually learned this technique
from my ancestors.
(Brenda laughs)
- All right, seriously.
- Okay.
- [Brenda] Back to the boi.
(bell dings)
- Tuck him into bed.
- Woo, woo!
- All right, so the third
one is now in the oven.
After they kinda bake off,
I'm gonna check on them.
I'm gonna put them back into the fridge.
They're gonna hold a lotta heat.
They're gonna need a
lotta time to cool down.
Tomorrow, we're gonna try to look
into how we can assemble it.
I really want it to look like this.
See you guys tomorrow.
(bright music)
Hey guys, it's day two.
I'm gonna check on the cheesecakes
that I put in the freezer
to see how they've set.
Hopefully it still
looks like this picture.
Let's go check it out.
All right, Brenda, I got some good news,
and I got some bad news.
Okay, so the bad news
is, the red velvet one,
it somehow didn't rise enough,
or it rose and it just
deflated all the way.
If I cut into it, it's
gonna look like that.
And that's gonna be a no from me, dog.
- [Brenda] Okay, these
ones look pretty good.
- Yeah, so the brownie
one looks pretty good.
So I think what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna try
to get the cake batter as close
to the consistency of
brownie batter as possible.
If you see the bottom
here, that's really cool.
I want the top to look like that.
So that's why I'm gonna do it again.
(upbeat music)
I don't know if you can see this,
but the batter is a lot
different than last time.
It's a lot thicker.
Do I dare say, thick?
The batter's so thick, got me working out.
(Brenda laughing)
Batter's in.
I'm gonna give it one more
shot, put it back in the oven,
and hopefully it just really stays flat.
(upbeat music)
I hope it stays level.
I really need this to sorta be flat,
or else it's gonna be another retry.
Woo, okay.
Woo!
Ooh, look at this.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
I think this is good to go.
(upbeat music)
- [Brenda] Oh God, oh God, oh God.
- I think if we're doing cheesecakes,
kinda makes sense to do
some cream cheese frosting.
So, got my little bad boi.
Better not wobble on me, Bertha, come on.
(bell dings)
This is so cool, it does
all the work for me.
I don't have to freakin' stir forever.
(machine stirring)
Do you guys know how much
sugar frosting has in it?
Cause it's a lot.
Dude, I need to record
this for my mixtape.
Yeah, we in the studio, here at Tasty,
trying to pull off something crazy,
I don't know how long it's gonna take,
but I'll mix the icing on that cake.
- [Brenda] Ohh.
- Woo!
[Brenda Laughing]
- Okay guys, we're gonna go and assemble
the cake now, probably the scariest part
with three layers that are super heavy.
Hopefully this frosting
is thick enough to glue
the layers together, as
well as make it smooth
on the outside.
It's gonna be kinda tough, but here we go.
- Yay, it's a cake parade!
- C'mon.
Woo!
- [Brenda] Lots of focus here.
- [Alvin] Pressure's
on, I guess, God damn.
(upbeat music)
(whistles)
- Gorgeous
- I hope it's enough, I
really don't wanna make more.
- [Brenda] Maybe if I stopped eating it?
- Oh my God, no wonder.
(upbeat music)
You know chocolate ganache drip on top,
throw some nice chopped chocolate chunks
on the bottom rim of the cake.
- [Brenda] You and your layers.
- Love my layers Brenda.
(enchanting music)
I'mma call this big boy,
I'm gonna call it Bubb.
B-U-B-B.
(dings)
Oh, it's a heavy boy Bubb.
Why you gotta be so big?
(enchanting music)
- [Brenda] Please lift with your core.
- Yes, ma'am.
I'll do squats.
- [Brenda] Bend your knees.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
It's here!
- Houston, the eagle had landed.
- [Brenda] That looks real.
- It is real.
- [Brenda] Ew, ew.
(dramatic music)
- Phew, that was close.
(knives sharpening)
Here we go.
(Dramatic music)
- [Brenda] Oh my God, yes!
(dramatic music)
- I'm only half way
there, just keep going.
Come on.
Hard AF.
Let's go, cut this boy open.
- Okay, okay.
(Alvin huffing and puffing)
- I feel like I'm through.
- [Brenda] There it is.
Ohh.
(upbeat music)
- Gotta say, turned a lot better
than I thought it was.
I'm pretty proud of
this, I think it's kinda
this crazy idea that I had that I'm kinda
able to make into reality.
Pretty happy with it, I hope
I can feed a lot of people
with this.
The layers came out
but I really wanna know
if it's actually gonna
taste good so I hope
these people like it.
If it looks good but doesn't taste good
then we didn't win Brenda.
- I love cookie dough.
(laughing)
- This is very chocolatey.
- I like it, I like
having all the different
flavors together.
- Mmmm.
- Wow.
- [Narrator] Good?
- Good is not even the word.
- I like the fact it's real cheesecake,
like the baked cheesecake,
he's done it again for us.
- [Narrator] Ohh.
- Triple-decker cheesecake.
- It always feels good
when I'm able to make
a food, sort of idea or
food dream into reality.
I like the way people can
smile when you feed them.
It also took a lot of restraint for me,
not to play a mix tapes
during the entire process,
because I knew I had to keep the cake cold
and if I played, it
would've just melted so...
- [Brenda] Stop it!
This is turning into a mix tape joke.
- Hey Brenda, you wanted final thoughts,
I'm giving you honest thoughts straight
from the heart.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)